good morning Joey how are you I'm not
better you don't okay what do you
remember about sacking Brady last season
I remember him arguing it and almost
getting it getting a call
what was he arguing whether his knee was
down usually good does he talk a lot who
does talk to you you know I've never
been too much of a crab talker myself so
I don't really get it get it at directed
towards me much so you know I really
haven't ever really can't point out one
guy who's been too terrible I was
reading where when you were 15 you were
recruited by Nick Saban and it came down
to Alabama and Ohio State is that true
yeah yeah it was pretty much at the end
of the process those are the two schools
that were the first options
okay did you how do you tell Nick Saban
you're not going to Alabama yeah I don't
remember if I directly called him or
what or I thought the guy who I was I
was being recruited by but I just
remember when I had to tell them I was
it was tough because they were kind of
the first ones to make an impact in the
first ones in the process but uh you
know they were totally understanding
with her you remember that call with
Urban Meyer when you said you were going
to Ohio State oh yeah I was in office
when I commended with with my family and
it was pretty quick after my second
visit and the kind of kind of rushed to
rush things a little bit but you know I
never forgot that decision I was also
wondering back when you were in high
school that you had videos that went
viral when you would do back flips in
the gym and then then dad said
shut it down yeah yeah he had to be the
one to to wanna broadcast backflip and
make a video there's an unnatural I hear
myself but thank you I stopped doing it
the eg that we thank you we just thought
it was a cool trick you like you weren't
allowed to do in at Ohio State I don't
know if I would do it if even if he'd
want me to it's a lot of stress yeah
yeah yeah no all the way yeah did you
watch the Ohio State Michigan game yeah
there was a lot of fun
who did you want you a lot of fun I just
watched it with my brother and my my mom
was in town my aunt and her little kids
my little cousins nine eleven and
thirteen three of the biggest states
ever so um how did how was Nick watching
the game he was pumped up he was on the
edge of the couch screaming and
everything it was it was fun to see how
much good telly okay sorry good how much
counseling did you give him on you know
cuz that's tough to miss miss out on
that game and I know there's a bigger
picture here but what advice were you
giving him about trying to come back
from the injury and if he was going to
play this season at Ohio State you know
he's not even close to being ready to
play football right now so in his mind
he's he's okay with what's going on
right now he he knows what he did to the
team all the time and effort and
everything he put in for the team and
his teammates and how much they all mean
to how much he means to them so right
now he's feeling okay with the process
it was really tough at first for him
leaving his teammates of course and not
being able to get a chance at a national
campus all he wanted Holly wanted to do
but uh you know he's a smart kid and he
can see the bigger picture himself so I
didn't really need to do much talking to
him
Joey Bosa the Chargers defensive end
they've got the Steelers coming up on
Sunday night have you sacked
Roethlisberger before no no no we'll see
this weekend
you see bigger than you I think he's not
faster let's put it though he's not
faster dude he might and he might have a
few get a few pounds on me I don't know
if it's good times but I also had I
thought it was a good idea that you had
I don't know if it played out that way
like you thought it was going to when
you when you tried to do the MVP chant
for Philip Rivers would you describe
that effort that you had you know 25 to
25 I think we need to get a few more
critical bands I'll be better how odd is
that then it's not really a home-field
advantage for you in the second half it
was pretty fun yeah but you guys are a
Super Bowl contender okay why are people
coming out gonna take a little while for
Sur fans to find their way out here to
LA but um you know you're seeing it
everywhere I'm feeling the support on
Instagram and you know whenever I go
anywhere so they're definitely out there
yeah yeah I know but you guys are having
such a great year I hate to say where
you don't have a home-field advantage
and it doesn't feel that way but good
luck against the Steelers you're
certainly going to feel their home field
advantage coming up on Sunday night yeah
Joey thanks for joining us we appreciate
your time good luck against the Steelers
yeah and so Joey Bosa for more Dan
Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]